bonsoir merci de créer en direct avec
nous ce soir sur rtl france est bien
d'accord donc à in extremis on l'a 10
entre londres et bruxelles et que
c'était passé on a oublié gibraltar
gibraltar à la différence des
départements où outre mer français ne
fait pas partie du royaume uni est donc
ce territoire n'est pas concernée par
l'accord qui a été arraché comme vous
l'avait dit à la dernière minute le 24
décembre
gibraltar n'est pas à la différence de
l'irlande du nord par exemple ne fait
pas partie du royaume uni est donc ce
territoire est gouvernée par d'autres
règlements dans votre reportage vous
avez me semble-t-il confondez deux
choses très différentes
vous avez montré les images de files
d'attentes de camion près de douvres qui
se sont accumulés un peu avant noël
mais pourquoi se sont elles se sont
elles à que accumulé c'est que de cesser
ces files d'attentes et bien c'est parce
que la france pour des raisons
sanitaires a fermé les frontières a
fermé ses frontières vis-à-vis du
royaume-uni
or ce dont il est question maintenant
quand vous évoquez le break 6 duos
ce n'est pas de fermer la frontière avec
gibraltar entre gibraltar et l'espagne
mais de mettre une frontière dur c'est à
dire de mettre des contrôles mais ça
c'est très différent des contrôles
frontières il y en a non pas par tour
mais il y en a quand même en europe
aujourd'hui quand vous allez de la
france royaume uni
vous devez passer par les contrôles vous
devez montrer votre passeport
à la différence de ce que vous faites si
vous aussi vous allez de la france en
allemagne
donc il y a déjà des frontières dur ce
qu'on appelle des frontières dur des
frontières comorienne locale sur un mot
sur le statut un mot sur le statut quand
même de gibraltar pour qu'on comprenne
bien puisque la ministre des affaires
étrangères espagnol a lancé un ultimatum
tout de même au royaume uni 2
cent douze heures pour trouver une
solution oui mais le statut n'est pas en
question le gibraltar est un territoire
britannique depuis le traité d'utrecht
en 1713 bien sûr l'espagne revendique la
souveraineté sur ce territoire
l'espagne n'ont jamais vraiment accepté
le traité du traict mais je ne crois pas
sincèrement que l'espagne va faire un
vin passe sur gibraltar
à moins que son allusion que nous avons
entendu tout à l'heure dans votre
reportage à une frontière fermée ne
soient une menace peut être que
l'espagne peut être madrid est en train
de de menacer gibraltar et le royaume
uni alors est-ce que des négociations
est ce que des négociations qui vont qui
vont débuter pour justement éviter que
gibraltar se retrouve l'idée vous l'avez
double et là tout à l'heure je n'ai pas
entendu ce qu'elle a dit en espagnol
si l ai dit si la ministre a dit que la
frontière serait fermée à ce moment là
il s'agit très clairement d'une menace
l'espagne voudrait évidemment rendre la
dite la vie difficile pour gibraltar ça
c'est sûr mais les négociations bien sûr
il y en a bien sûr mais même dans le cas
où elle échouerait le fait qu'il y ait
une frontière durée des contrôles ce
n'est pas grave ce n'est pas la fin du
monde
encore une fois je répète il y en a
aussi ailleurs en europe il y en avait
ans pour aller en suisse jusqu'à n'y a
pas très longtemps il y en a toujours
pour aller en angleterre donc une
frontière dur ce n'est pas si grave que
cela
dans l'hypothèse où les négociations
échoueraient
ça veut dire que au niveau de l'anc la
britannique les impacts économiques ne
seront pas si catastrophique que cela
qu'est ce qui est une vraie crainte 1 et
si la frontière est fermée la vie serait
très difficile mais encore une fois je
ne sais pas ce que la ministre a dit si
elle a parlé de fermer la frontière de
faire un blocus contre jyp altran ça
serait quand même extraordinaire
je ne pense pas que la traduction a été
fidèle à moins qu'elle fait des menaces
très grossière si par contre il ya des
contrôles qui sont ré entre
introduit à la frontière cela ne me
semblait pas la fin du monde
ne mélangeons pas les choses le royaume
uni qui est la cinquième économie au
monde vient de conclure un accord avec
l'union européenne qui va réglementer
600 milliards de commerce d'euros de
commerce par an vous venez de nous
parler de l'accord avec la chine
d'accord avec la chine concerne 100
milliards alors avec le royaume uni ces
600 milliards donc c'est six fois plus
important que la chine
et là vous mélangez ça avec gibraltar j
printemps c'est un village c'est trente
quatre mille personnes qui va très très
certainement survivre même dans
l'hypothèse d'un blocus espagnol sur
quoi je mets une pression il ya une
pression espagnole puisque un ultimatum
lancé donc faut bien se préoccuper aussi
de gibraltar quand même oui mais est-ce
que vous vous êtes en train de me dire
que l'espagne va fermer la frontière
comme franco en 1969
les léventins brixi dur donc oui mais
c'est ce que je suis en train de vous
dire un proxy tueur ça veut dire la
réintroduction de contrôles aux
frontières
ça ne veut pas dire la fermeture de la
frontière vous ne pouvez pas mélanger
deux choses s'il y a des contrôles ça va
sans doute ralentir un peu le trafic
évidemment mais si la frontière est
fermée par contre à ce moment là cela
devient effectivement un grand problème
mais il ne faut pas mélanger briques
site duo qui est déjà une expression un
peu biaisé qui équivaut à la
réintroduction de contrôles à la
frontière
il ne faut pas mélanger cela avec la
fermeture de la frontière
ce à laquelle je ne crois pas donc pas
tannique donne le clan ben voilà pas de
panique
merci beaucoup à vous je rappelle que
vous êtes universitaire à britannique
spécialisée en géo politique et
philosophie politique